the Joe Rogan experience so if you if
Harvey Weinstein convicted donut jail
son and that's just in New York he still
has to get tried out here oh he's kind
of done a bunch of trials that's just
one have you seen how much he is aged -
no that's like eight months like me and
my wife were watching him on the news
last night when we go I saw him on a red
carpet a couple years before and he was
like vibrant and just the stress and the
guiltiness and everything is just
beating him down I don't think he'll
even make it to jail I mean I might kill
himself I told my wife that lat
because yeah you're gonna die in jail
well he's probably depressed so deeply
imagine going from being the toast of
the town posing with Oprah on top of the
world go on the red carpet everybody
loves you everybody thanks you when they
get their academy award have you ever
seen the compilation of all the stars
thanking harvesting uh-huh and then many
of them went on to accuse him accuse him
later of being a monster but meanwhile
they're just praising him well it's but
you don't you have to play that game
[ __ ] don't you I don't know I guess it
but any act about this yesterday Owen
Smith and I we're talking about this
yesterday we're on the podcast we're
talking about like how much I'm so happy
I don't have to go on auditions and I
don't act and I'm not I don't want to be
a part of that anymore that's one of the
reason people think like God why is
everybody Hollywood so fake because
they're all trying to get cast in
something that's true they're all trying
to get accepted by producers and casting
directors and in executives and so
they're all just like hedging their bets
like playing it safe like a guy on the
first date just a [ __ ] artist just
like a [ __ ] slick guy with loose
morals on a first date trying real hard
is this him getting arrested and how
long ago was that
where's his [ __ ] Walker walking
perfect now how come how long ago was
that this was yesterday we go he's
walking yeah he was all I think why they
have to cuff him they think that fat
[ __ ] is gonna kick anybody's ass I like
it what's up with that no element but
isn't it weird no it's great the cuffing
thing is weird when you like if
someone's I guess if you know a [ __ ]
run
you can run where's little [ __ ]
toothpick legs in a big old belly let
that meatball belly anywhere the two
name running but here's the thing it's
like I guess he's accused of violent
crime so you have to cuff him right if
he's accused of murder and they're
convicted you gotta cuff him what
happens to him if he goes to jail does
he get Epstein like do president III
know we any kids if you mess with any
kids yeah I thought so he doesn't look
like that anymore
that's probably two three years ago
right oh that was when he initially got
arrested yeah I about to say that's not
him well I know he looks that was one of
the things that the court artists there
was an artist that drew him throughout
the case and she was saying that you
could see his deterioration is physical
deterioration over the course of the
trial have you seen him lately
no did you oh you got to pull up the
video of him like yesterday it literally
him walking out you know he looks twenty
years older I wonder if that Walker
shit's real you think that worn out [ __ ]
was I don't think it's real but I think
it became real whoa don't get done done
that's right I think it was yeah look at
that look just his face yeah I think it
was a thing where oh let's play it for
the court and then he just got so broken
down through the process what she
deserved
mm-hm and it just took a toll on a man
look at him this is the video you just
showed is like two years old it was made
when 18 May 2018 you got him now but
he's lost most of his hair yeah he looks
so old and tired he's probably not
getting any sleep
he's [ __ ] beaten man and he was on
top of the world if if there is karma
right if Karma's real that's the Karma
cuz this guy was on the top of the world
but he was like forcing everyone yeah
Sarkis Dirk so you want to be a star
suck my tits like demonic yeah I know
come on in now karma is like Tamas
saying do you want to suck my dick I
don't want to I don't but I don't want
to all right come here get over here you
wanna make you a star I'm sorry sorry I
don't tell anybody about this like whoa
and then sign and then his contract had
it in there you heard about that okay
like they had a disclaimer in his
contract not only didn't have a
disclaimer for one count of sexual
harassment two
you get you have to pay up this amount
three counts you have to pay up that
amount like he would lose money based on
how many different counts of sexual
harassment he had so they were
negotiating depended upon him being a
predator like they kind of knew what
what do you mean kind of if they they
knew he knew if you're putting in a
contract you know well that's the other
thing how many people are also liable
here oh my thing is when of the agents
go into jail the ones that kept sending
all the actresses to the guy than when
they knew they knew everybody's an
actress can say hey Harvey Weinstein
raped me and then the agency says listen
you want this job or not like those
those people those people but if you're
an agent and you've known Harvey
Weinstein for four or five years or ten
years and you know he's been doing this
but yet you continue to send actresses
right to this guy you have some type of
responsibility to yes
but here's the question did they think
that he was just a pig and he was trying
to talk those girls into willingly
having sex with him which many did or
did they think he was a rapist because
he was both of those things apparently
yes he was a guy who had sex with girls
who were willing to [ __ ] themselves out
to be in movies and he also forced
himself on women who did not want to
have anything to do with him so he had
both of those things were going on but
you don't think the agencies that were
sending all these big actresses in they
didn't know they knew the book types a
they had some girls willing and some
girls are saying they're rape
you don't think question you don't think
any actress ever go went back to their
agent go
I'm never going in again I got raped and
then that and then that agent was like
all right I'm not gonna send you any
more but hey over here
go ahead and Harvey well I like the way
you're negotiating here because the way
you're saying it doesn't give a person
out you're saying you don't think
because no one's saying that they don't
think that no one's arguing that they
don't think that's you saying you don't
think that so you're learning from that
book yes very clever I wouldn't say it
that way
what I would say is if there's a high
likelihood that they at least
suspected he had forced himself on some
women and there was probably some rumors
there was a hundred percent likelihood
they knew he was a pig there was a high
likelihood that there were some stories
about some things that he had did that
were probably criminal high likelihood I
don't know how many people were privy to
those stories I don't know how deep it
got in whether I mean like if you're an
agent how many actresses do you actually
get to send to Harvey Weinstein how many
you know I don't know I'm sure I'm sure
whoever he wanted to see right but I
don't know what that number is I don't
know how much they actually knew well we
can be pretty sure of at this point is
there's no way all these women are lying
oh no I know they're all I believe look
I know some hit talks about the time he
threatened to murder Harvey that's a
great story like this is right after
Gwyneth Paltrow was a Harvey Weinstein
made an advancement on Gwyneth Paltrow
and Brad Pitt confronted and said I'll
[ __ ] kill you you do that again
so this is the thing Brad Pitt knew
right so if Brad Pitt knows and he's one
of the biggest movie stars these agents
know he / Paltrow he approached
Weinstein outside play premiere in 1995
and he told him if you ever make her
feel uncomfortable again I'll kill you
but this is a joke this is in 1995 25
years ago bro so you're telling me that
these agents and the industry we are I
didn't even know the guy but I heard
these stories right this what it said is
that he touched her inappropriately and
invited her to his bedroom she told her
then-boyfriend Brad Pitt about it see
that's what I think most people had
heard and that's gross but it's not
crosses and it's not great see that I
think most people knew about that [ __ ]
and Brad Pitt was willing to kill him
over that which I love yeah
[Applause]